so um we had a call maybe it was last
week maybe the week before where a
viewer asked me what do I think happened
to the whole Matt Gates thing the
investigation charges were expected
forthcoming Etc uh and I said I don't
know um that these things can take a
while I don't you know I said at the
time I don't know if Matt Gates is going
to be charged it's not looking good but
I don't know if Matt Gates is going to
be charged the latest news is that Matt
Gates has hired a bevy
uh of sex crime lawyers to defend him
and it makes sense that if you expect
charges
of murder you would hire lawyers who are
experts in defending you against murder
charges that sort of is logical that
makes sense and he's entitled to get
lawyers but this is a sign of maybe the
direction that things are going best
Levin writing for Vanity Fair uh that
the last time we checked in on the legal
comings and goings of Matt Gates things
were not looking great for him
um since the news broke this spring that
he was under investigation for paying
women for sex and separately for
sleeping with a minor and transporting
her across state lines the hits have
included Gates's former wingman pleading
guilty and having charges dropped from
33 to 6 in exchange for cooperation that
that didn't look great for Gates the
news that Gates had allegedly paid the
women he compensated through online
payment platforms leaving a digital
paper trail not good
the news that the feds are additionally
looking into obstruction of justice
charges
his former wingman reportedly giving the
feds years of venmo transactions and
thousands of photos and videos and Gates
being heckled on the street by stranger
Stout shouting people think you're a
pedophile Gates has denied allegations
but the latest news in terms of his
lawyers uh suggests that this could be
real trouble Gates has hired a major
team of lawyers the team according to
reporter Roger sullenberger includes
attorney Mark mu Casey who has defended
the Trump organization in a number of
legal battles Isabel kirschner a top
criminal defense lawyer who represented
Robert Hadden the ex-columbia university
gynecologist accused listen to this by
200 patients of sexual assault
ultimately pleaded guilty uh with regard
to two patients lost his medical license
didn't get time in prison so it seems
that Isabelle kirschner is the right
person to hire meanwhile Gates's
campaign has returned the service
retained the Services of New York trial
lawyer Mark furnich who has the
distinction of having defended some of
history's most notorious criminals
including Jeffrey Epstein the Mexican
drug lord Joaquin Guzman AKA El Chapo
and Keith Rainier who was sentenced to
120 years in prison for running the
nxivm sex cult where women were branded
like physically branded and forced into
sexual slavery all of this suggests
Gates is taking the possibility of
winding up in legal trouble very very
seriously spokesperson for Gates
declined to declined a request for a
comments so there's a lot going on here
all right in the context of are there
ever going to be charges this signals we
should be keeping an eye on this because
there could be charges very very soon
and they could be very serious charges
now here's my view on the lawyer thing
if you ever need to defend yourself for
any crime you're accused of whether
you're guilty or innocent doesn't matter
whether you're guilty or innocent if
you're accused of a crime you should
hire a lawyer that specializes in
defending people against that type of
crime any sensible person would do that
given reasonable means so Matt Gates can
hire whoever he wants this is a signal
of what may be coming and that's it if I
were being criminally tried I would want
a criminal lawyer if the criminal
charges were murder I would want someone
experienced in defending murder there's
no question about it the fact that he's
hiring these people signals that there
are some really serious charges
potentially coming related to sex crimes
doesn't mean he's guilty he gets his day
in court every time we talk about
possible charges people write to me and
they say David do you not support due
process do you not support innocent
until proven guilty first of all sort of
like do I support gravity it's like we
have due process and people are innocent
until proven guilty he gets his day in
court everybody's entitled to that but
this signals that the charges May well
be coming however
he really shouldn't be allowed to use
campaign funds for these lawyers because
these are personal charges now there are
people making the the argument
um that part of this is retaining
counsel
for his campaign so that if there are
charges the campaign for re-election can
continue unfet it feels pretty weak to
me the the charges are for personal
actions and he should not be allowed to
use campaign funds for his defense
I feel very strongly about that uh the
there's already been reportedly twenty
five thousand dollars for a lawyer been
paid by the gates campaign even though
the charges stem from Gates alleged
personal actions that's not good that
shouldn't be allowed but uh let's buckle
up because uh this really could get very
interesting very very quickly